great see again he looked great and I
couldn't help but notice look at the
cover that book that's a glamour shot of
you that's like Vogue it's gorgeous
yes I'm so proud of it yeah it didn't
take forever to pick I I don't know it's
weird to have a picture to choose a
picture for a book that's gonna be on
the shelves for let's hope forever right
yeah did you pick it yeah I was kind of
a brat about it actually cuz the
publisher the publishing house I work
with HarperCollins they were like this
is the one and I was like that's not the
one and they were like no we know what
we're doing and I'm like I know what I
know what I look like did they want you
to look tougher no they didn't they
wanted I don't even know what picture
that they wanted but they wanted
something else and I don't know the
eyebrows look great I mean that's the
key thank you yeah yeah and mom has to
love that picture I'm sure I'm sure she
does yes now as far as what's in the
book yeah now at first I thought it
might be one of those let me just recap
all the great things I've done and then
you have the DUI and I didn't know if
you change direction of this book after
that DUI
yeah that's a good question I actually
did so before the DUI happened it was
gonna be kind of one of those puff books
like look at how great my career was
amazing
and then then the humbling DUI happened
and I was like you know what I've got a
lot of stuff going on inside of me that
I need to actually talk about and I need
to be honest about because I do even
even before the DUI I liked I considered
myself to be pretty honest and open
there was just like this one thing that
I was kind of keeping pretty secret and
the secret itself kept manifesting and
maybe maybe more substance abuse and
more substance abuse throughout the
years so me telling the story in hopes
to heal throughout the process of
writing the book and then more
importantly now that it's published to
push it out into the world to help other
people
when did substance abuse if you even
want to call it that when did you start
using cocaine or alcohol when did you
know you had a problem yeah so it was
just alcohol in terms of the abuse I
have been drinking since
I was of legal age probably before then
and it was one of those things that for
a long time I was using to normalize
myself to make me feel because because
soccer was such a big part of my life
that I wanted to do something like the
normal kids did right in high school and
in college I wanted to do I wanted to
feel normal
the quote-unquote normal and then you
know in off seasons and in off weeks
with the national team you know I was
never drunk on on the field and I never
was that bad thankfully but when I when
I when I did have those off times I
would definitely binge and it wasn't
until the latter part of my career where
it probably was affecting me on the
field right the length of time than
which of it that I was actually abusing
alcohol in that way and then and then
for me knowing that alcohol you you you
you degenerate your brain degenerates
after years and years of use so this DUI
was the perfect moment for me to get
really honest with myself to get as
humiliated and shamed in the media as I
was rightfully so you know I don't I
don't I don't deny that that fact but it
was the right wake-up call and finally I
woke up and I've been sober ever since
well sometimes when you're a star
athlete like the other you're on a
different plateau so by drinking you've
now become normal your wanna you come
down to them in some ways like you know
she's a star athlete oh now she's gonna
come down and slum it with us
was that part of it that you you wanted
to be normal you wanted to be accepted
as just another person yeah and I don't
I don't think it was like go and
somehing with a normal folk like I
consider myself a pretty normal person
and the thing is is like when you the
the more attention and fame that I got
and celebrity that I got throughout the
years everybody wanted a drink with me
you know and like I'm really sorry to
all your listeners and all those guys
out there that want to drink whisky with
me I would have drank you under the
table I would have done it
but now I'm sober and we'll just have to
you'll just have to be okay with us
playing golf together did you ever have
one of those moments where somebody
reminded you were told you that it was
bad yeah I mean throughout my marriage
to Sarah I she was she was pretty on me
for it and was worried for me it wasn't
about nagging me it was she was worried
for my health and and I think for a long
time I knew soccer kept me within the
lines pretty much right and then the
idea of not having soccer to keep me
somewhat in somewhat control that scared
me and I think I started to spin out of
control out of control towards the end
but also you were playing great and and
then not in the last few years of my
career like let's be honest I'm pretty
conscious and aware of my ability I hit
a hit probably 32 33 and I started to
degenerate and to not play as well yes
we won the World Cup in 2015 but if
you'll remember I wasn't playing did you
know that it was time yeah yeah I knew
that it was time in fact I if we had won
the World Cup in 2011 I would have
retired after we won the gold medal in
2012 I only kept playing because I
didn't have that World Cup championship
to to look at I don't even have the
trophy right but it's just like it's
this metaphorical thing that we have
sometimes we'll look at athletes or look
at stars and and there we want them to
be stars we want them to be perfect
mm-hmm and do you feel like you let
people down or do you because you're
gonna get people who are eventually
gonna realize that they'll thank you
because you did this right that you said
this because you help people yeah but
you were put up there you're you're
you're a bee womp I mean you're red
white and blue right and then this
happened like the little girls or
parents may look up to you um I don't
care really I'd have to be I have to be
myself I have to be in my truth I would
rather be honest and loved then shiny
and admired because I think that the the
pedestals that we put people on
celebrities or athletes it's all the
you know it doesn't matter it's not
really who they are you only show the
world what you want people to see right
even though you're on the on the radio
on television for hours and hours every
morning you still only show people what
you want them to see and for me doing
that for so many years made me worse
made my problem worse and it magnified
all those issues and the fraud that I
felt like I was so you're leading a
double life I felt like I was you know
and I feel like a lot of celebrities do
well sure I really do and you know for
me my problem was that I have an
addictive personality so that feeling
and and living that double life could
you know spin out of control like it did
it wasn't healthy for me the book is
called forward a memoir available in
bookstores online as your mom read this
I don't know actually
I'm not sure if she did she know that
you had problems um she didn't know the
extent of the problems she didn't know
the prescription pill problem that I was
that I had prescription pill abusing
problem towards the end of my career I
think she's scared because she knows
that I was in so much pain and I wasn't
able to talk about it but that's the
thing about any abuse or addiction
issues that people have is people are so
ashamed of it you know and there's a
stigma attached to it that's like you're
bad or you're weak and it's just not
true right you're in pain and you're
suffering so if you are out there and
you need help just just talk to somebody
even if it's your mom even if it's even
if it's your your coworker talk to
somebody because as soon as you start
telling your truth
you're gonna be able to get better and
get help I want to come back I want to
ask you you had the conversation with
your mom when you came out I I want to
talk to you about that yes and you do
write about that I do I don't know what
was tougher to tell her you had an
alcohol problem or substance abuse or
that you were coming out and I'll
someone asked you about Hope Solo
playing with her so we'll continue with
abby wambach the book is forward a
memoir available in bookstores and
online more after this on the Dan
Patrick show the book is forward a
memoir abby wambach the new book
available bookstores online
two-time Olympic gold medalist and it's
not a puff book believe me if it had to
be there's some tough tough parts in
I'm sure to revisit but Abby's talked
about that in the first segment with us
Tim Tebo will join us in 15 minutes from
now but let me go back to you'll have to
have a conversation with your mom about
substance abuse but you've had that
conversation with her about coming out
as a lesbian but how old were you when
they had that conversation with your mom
um I was 22 when I first came out to my
mom and mm-hmm
you know she is Irish Catholic and I was
brought up in kind of a conservative
smaller town Rochester New York and so
you know she understandably maybe didn't
understand it at the time and so it's
been an evolution the way that my mom
has kind of come into knowing my
sexuality and have been accepting of it
and and for that opportunity to like
help her evolve you know I'm really
proud of that and so when I actually had
to have these conversations with her
about my substance abuse problem I think
she was not it wasn't it's like
comparing apples and oranges right
because first of all my substance abuse
problem was behavioral things that that
I was you know I was sick and coming out
is like telling my mom like Who I am
right so those are kind of different
things she's just more scared for me now
because she was worried about the way
the public would perceive it she was
upset that I was in so much pain and I
wasn't able to actually tell her about
it and and that's just the thing with
with any kind of substance abuse or
addictions that people are just shamed
of it and you keep it inside have you
got a negative reaction though actually
no I haven't and I think that that will
allow her to feel better about this
whole process but I I think that at
first when I got the DUI it was a little
bit of a punishment I was trying to
punish myself I'm just gonna tell
everybody everything and show that I am
the good person that I am and I am like
authentic and all this stuff as you roll
your eyes well I mean you know at the
time I was like you know you're gonna do
no wrong authentic is like that like the
trendy word that's happening everybody's
calling themselves authentic and I'm
like whatever I define that word like
years ago
so you you have that conversation with
your mom and then as it has the
relationship um it's good you know I
mean I love my mom so much and we have
come so far and you know it's not easy
to be the mother of me because I was
kind of a wild kid I wanted to do
everything myself I wanted everything to
be my choice I wanted to make my own
mistakes and I didn't want any advice
you know I was kind of a jerk in some
ways but that's part of my personality
that allowed me to find the success that
I was able to did you play that way yeah
I mean would I hate playing you well
here's the thing I was a good teammate
but I also was really I had really high
standards for myself personally
individually
did you talk too much I never really
talked smack I talked like fun smack
like you know I don't even know I have
like zero example that's coming sound
corny if you yeah like I don't know like
so take that yeah more where that came
from
yeah exactly suck in China I mean I
think that there would be a few more
expletives Oh like that it was that kind
of fun what happened with a US soccer at
the Olympics um on the field I think
that they just got really tight they got
nervous I think that they weren't
performing that well throughout the
tournament they had moments of of doing
well but overall for me they didn't they
didn't have a soul
they they they kind of looked like a
team that we're trying to define
themselves but trying too hard if that
makes sense
but were you that soul I don't I don't
would you try to did you try to be that
soul um I'm course I felt like that was
part of my job as a leader is to inspire
people to be better than they think that
they can be and Kris here and Christian
pone like my counterpart captain she she
did all the other stuff right I was kind
of the emotional person and so even late
in the game the the last game that they
ended up losing at Sweden you know you
look around and people had kind of like
deer in headlight I
on and that scared me I saw it and I'm
like screaming from my couch right I'm
like come on like what are you doing
like let's go you know and I have
nothing but love and respect and I know
how hard it is to play in the stage and
I know everything like has to come and
happen perfectly to advance and big
championship games but I do think that
something was missing and it's not me it
was just something there was like this
this thing that was missing that I
couldn't put my finger on did you like
Hope Solo as a teammate that is a very
pointed question I think that I
respected her ability on the field hope
and I clashed a lot right we butted
heads and there's a lot of reasons for
that number one we were very opposite
ends of the spectrum by ways in which we
we played did you fight yeah yeah we
argued we argued quite a bit but I'm
physical did you oh no no no oh that
would never happen okay um no we we
argued quite a bit and that we had kind
of this love-hate relationship where
we're like sisters where you know like
we get on each other's nerves or I'd say
something and it piss her off or she'd
say something and it upset me so there
was a lot of that going on and you know
I think that we found a way to manage
and work with each other because
throughout the time that I played there
was no better goalkeeper right and
that's something that hope will always
have in my mind that she was the best
goalkeeper when I when I was playing
hands down without question but was she
difficult to work with the times hell
yeah and was I probably you know because
we're these big personalities and when
two big personalities walk in the same
room you're bound to around to have some
fun competition did you have any
problems with her comments about how
Sweden played calling them calories yeah
I have big problems of that I don't
think you ever point you never call
another team coward after you've just
been beaten right the rules in the game
are the rules in the game and you don't
want to be a sore loser not when you're
the best team in the world right that's
just that to me looks weak when you're
pointing fingers at another team that
just beat you and call them cut like
that's like that's like playground stuff
right
a professional stand up and say you know
what they beat us at our own game they
played better than us today call it a
spade a spade like if I were Sweden it's
exactly what I would have done that's
exactly the team Sweden has always been
and it has always been known to play
that's like the way that they've always
played but if we go back ten years if
she's ten years younger and she makes
this comment is she suspended by USA
soccer fired I don't know because I
think that the suspension was a Lifetime
Achievement Award right well it was I
mean in terms of her longevity on the
team and how many mistakes and stuff
that she made you know and I'm not
judging her because listen I've made
mistakes also but for her I think it was
a compilation of all these things
happening so ten years ago I don't think
she's made all those mistakes
right and so I think that that in the
end is why you have soccer decided well
I thought it was easy to suspend her now
because I think she's past her prime or
at least they want to move on from Hope
Solo and this was a convenient out for
them that was the feeling I got yeah I
mean it it may look like that and I
wasn't in those rooms or wasn't a part
of those conversations thankfully you
know I think that you know when when
something like that happens and you know
what it's like to have been there yep in
those rooms in those conversations it
was actually really nice to be home this
time I was like okay this is interesting
to be on the outside how important is it
to be introduced as the greatest u.s.
women's soccer player or you the
greatest US soccer player in history
they're all difference between women and
young or just being recognized as the
greatest US soccer player of all time
yeah I mean listen first of all there I
think that the the the greatest of all
time thing it's like so weird first of
all like anybody who actually is the
greatest of all time like doesn't think
that they are but do you want to be know
you want to be recognizes no nobody
wants to be recognized as that like the
greatest of all time only only like
Muhammad Ali who coined the phrase right
yeah he's the one all the rest of us are
just like peons like all the rest of us
they're just like little minions that he
does so so when you walk in the room and
then somebody goes it's a B greatest
soccer player
a soccer player of all time you don't
want somebody saying that I mean no I
want them to be like oh there's a B oh
yeah like I did I don't care about that
stuff I like legitimately it would make
me uncomfortable
if if like people attach greatest of all
time okay every time I walk into a room
then I don't want you guys to do that
anymore when I walk in the room okay
I've learned they had no idea that we
were you know embarrassing like I'm
sorry growing yes
I'm maturing wait till I put out my
memoir Abby Wambach's new book is
forward a memoir available in bookstores
online it's always great to see you
thank you and loved your honesty in the
book thanks Dan the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience